Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Comment naissent les œuvres d’art ?
Et en particulier, comment naissent
les formes dans les œuvres d’art ?
Celles que nous créons.
Mais celles qu’on trouve
dans la nature aussi.
Qu’est-ce qu’elles pourraient
nous apprendre ?
Et si, par exemple, disons... dans
les mouvements d’un danseur,
on retrouvait quelque chose
comme une branche de corail
ou un morceau d’écorce ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on pourrait en conclure
sur la naissance de ces formes ?
A l’âge de dix ans,
j’étais petit rat à l’école
de danse de l’Opéra de Paris
et je me posais déjà
ce genre de questions.
Je n’avais pas tellement
d’éléments de réponse.
D’autant que l’enseignement de la danse
classique n’encourage pas forcément
à créer de nouvelles formes
avec son corps.
Vous savez, on cherche plutôt
à reproduire les formes déjà existantes.
Et, à 18 ans, alors que j’étais en train
de devenir danseur professionnel,
un événement complètement imprévu est
venu réalimenter un peu ces questions
sur comment on crée des œuvres,
comment on crée des formes.
Je me suis gravement blessé
en dansant mon premier rôle de soliste.
J'ai dû arrêter définitivement
la danse classique.
Et ça m’a permis de mieux comprendre
comment on peut générer
de nouvelles formes
parce que je n’ai pas tout à fait
arrêté de danser.
J’ai plutôt choisi de danser différemment.
Et je me suis mis à peindre.
J’ai décidé, en fait, d’intégrer
les mouvements du danseur
dans ceux du peintre
pour ne plus seulement créer
des formes avec mon corps
mais les créer aussi sur la toile.
Lorsque vous peignez de cette façon-là,
vous commencez par poser
la toile à l’horizontale,
vous versez de la peinture liquide dessus,
beaucoup de peinture.
Évidemment, cette peinture va couler,
vous avez des formes qui apparaissent.
Et puis, vous pouvez orienter ces formes,
vous pouvez soulever un coin,
vous pouvez même
complètement emporter la toile.
Et à vrai dire, vous pouvez
vous mettre à danser avec le tableau.
Dans un premier temps,
en procédant de cette manière,
j’ai pu créer, par exemple,
ce type d’œuvre d’art.
Ici, vous voyez, je travaille chacun
de mes mouvements avec précision,
comme le ferait un danseur,
pour orienter les mouvements
de la peinture, les coulures,
et être au plus proche
de ce que je souhaite obtenir.
Mais évidemment, on ne va pas se mentir,
la peinture reste très liquide
donc en partie incontrôlable,
et le hasard, ici, a toute sa place.
Et d’ailleurs,
on ne le retrouve pas seulement
dans la façon dont la peinture va couler,
on retrouve le hasard aussi dans la façon
dont les couleurs vont se mélanger
ou d’ailleurs, parfois,
ne pas se mélanger, allez savoir.
On le retrouve dans la façon
dont la peinture va sécher,
dans les textures qui vont apparaître
quand elles sèchent.
Je vais vous dire :
le hasard, on le retrouve à tous les
niveaux de la création artistique.
Voilà, peut-être,
comment naissent les formes.
Dans les mouvements du corps
et dans ceux, en partie aléatoires,
de la peinture mise en mouvement.
Et c’est étonnant de se dire que
le hasard qui s’était manifesté à moi
d’abord sous la forme d’une fatalité,
au moment de ma blessure,
est devenu, ensuite, mon meilleur allié
quand il a fallu inventer
quelque chose de nouveau, créer.
Comme si, c’était mon attitude par rapport
au hasard qui avait changé la donne.
Et là, je crois qu’on tient
un point essentiel.
L’attitude que nous allons
adopter face aux imprévus
va radicalement changer
l’histoire qu’on va écrire.
Pour cette raison,
il est indispensable de comprendre
comment agit le hasard sur nos créations.
Vous voyez, par exemple,
dans l’expression orale,
la diversité des mots, le vocabulaire,
ça enrichit le langage.
De la même façon, dans la création
artistique, la diversité des formes,
notre capacité à en créer de nouvelles
enrichit l'expression artistique.
Alors, si nous voulons,
nous, en tant que peintre,
avancer et si tout un chacun
vous voulez avancer
dans ce que vous créez,
dans ce que vous entreprenez,
il faut être capable de comprendre
l’action du hasard sur tout ça.
Alors, prenons un exemple.
Vous avez une idée en tête,
vous voulez peindre quelque chose,
vous commencez, mais bien entendu,
le hasard va se manifester.
Vous n'allez pas obtenir exactement
ce que vous aviez prévu.
Le hasard vous propose
quelque chose d’autre.
Génial !
Et d’ailleurs, si vous recommencez
un grand nombre de fois,
il est certain que vous obtiendrez
à chaque fois quelque chose de différent.
Comme si le hasard vous proposait
un peu des variations sur un thème.
Vous avez une idée,
et lui va vous emmener une fois
un peu à gauche, un peu à droite,
un peu plus comme ci,
un peu plus comme ça.
Si on cherchait à représenter
par une image simple
cette action du hasard qui vous propose
une infinité de nouveautés
à partir de votre idée de départ,
je crois qu’on arriverait rapidement
à l’image d’un lichen.
Pourquoi le lichen ?
Outre que parfois certains de mes tableaux
lui ressemblent un peu,
le lichen est cette structure biologique
qui fascine les scientifiques,
notamment parce qu’il a tendance à pousser
dans toutes les directions
de façon indiscriminée.
Il va aussi bien à droite qu’à gauche,
en haut, en bas.
Il explore, si vous voulez,
toutes les dimensions de l’espace,
un peu comme le hasard va nous emmener
une fois plutôt dans cette direction,
et puis, une fois plutôt dans l’autre,
de façon parfaitement indiscriminée.
Ce lichen, c’est en quelque sorte
une image de l’action du hasard
sur ce que nous créons.
C’est une image,
mais ce n’est pas la seule.
Et je vais vous dire,
je ne suis pas certain que ce soit
forcément celle qui tienne le mieux compte
de notre capacité aussi un peu à orienter
ce que nous devenons, ce que nous faisons.
Dans le lichen, on ne retrouve pas
vraiment notre choix, notre volonté,
choisir sa direction.
Et vous voyez, par exemple,
si je regarde ce tableau-ci
que j’ai peint très récemment,
je trouve qu’il ressemble
quand même un peu à celui-là
que j’ai peint il y a beaucoup
plus longtemps.
Comme s’il y avait un peu
une ligne directrice,
un fil conducteur entre les deux.
Et si on regarde celui-là,
on le retrouve encore, ce fil conducteur.
Ce fil conducteur, je pense
qu’on en a tous besoin
dans ce que nous faisons.
Finalement, je ne suis pas parti dans
toutes les directions avec le hasard.
Je suis parti dans une seule
ou dans quelques-unes, éventuellement.
Alors,
quelle image on pourrait trouver pour
représenter cette action du hasard ?
Non pas qui nous éparpille
mais qui nous aide à aller plus fort
et plus certainement dans
la direction que nous voulons.
Cette image, c’est celle d’un glacier.
Le glacier, vous voyez, il est capable de
tracer sa route, régulière, sinueuse,
entre deux montagnes dont
les formes sont parfaitement aléatoires.
Il est capable d’imposer sa direction,
sa route, malgré les aléas géologiques.
Et même, je dirais, c’est plus que ça,
c’est un exemple de stabilité
dans un environnement
qui, lui, est instable, irrégulier.
Et ça, je crois qu'on peut s'en inspirer.
Oui, c’est ça finalement :
pour être artiste,
soyez peut-être comme un glacier.
C’est une image qui est plus intéressante
et plus riche que celle du lichen
parce qu’elle propose une autre attitude
face au hasard, une attitude active.
Ce n’est pas seulement être
insensible aux aléas,
mais c’est leur donner la place que
vous pensez devoir être la leur.
Et il est là, à mon avis,
le véritable travail artistique.
Ce n’est pas seulement comme on l’entend
parfois « laisser faire le hasard »,
c’est nouer avec lui
une relation complexe.
Lui laisser jouer son rôle,
mais sans renoncer, nous,
à jouer le nôtre.
Et il est parfaitement
possible de l’orienter
tout en restant à son écoute.
C’est en cela que le hasard est réellement
à la source de la création
sans pour autant remettre en cause
le travail des artistes, leur rôle.
Et c’est en cela d’ailleurs que
le hasard m’a permis de trouver ma voie.
Lentement, certes,
mais avec force et détermination.
Comme un glacier qui avance
lentement entre deux montagnes.
Donc, finalement,
pour donner sa juste place au hasard,
je crois qu’il nous reste
peut-être à en faire
notre partenaire de danse ?
Oui, c'est ça.
Pour la peinture comme pour le reste,
je crois qu’il s’agit avant tout
d’apprendre à danser avec le hasard.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)